AND IN THE LAST TWO MONTHS
THAT’S WHAT GOVERNORS ARE SEEING
LET’S BRING IN MISSOURI GOP
SENATOR JOSH HAWLEY ON THIS
SENATOR, IS THIS NEANDERTHAL
THINKING BECAUSE I’M LOOKING BY
THE STATES LISTINGS OF THE
STATES WITHOUT MASK MANDATES.
MISSOURI IS ONE OF THEM.
ARE YOU --
DO YOU HAVE ARCHAIC THINKING?
>> WHAT A UNITER JOE BIDEN IS.
YOU KNOW THIS IS MR. UNITY.
AND YET IF YOU DISAGREE WITH HIM
YOU’RE A NEANDERTHAL HE’S CALLED
PEOPLE WHO DISAGREE WITH HIM
NAZIS IT IS UNBELIEVABLE IN
MISSOURI WE ARE CALLED BY D.C.
CROWD FLYOVER COUNTRY SO WE’VE
GOTTEN THIS TREATMENT FOR YEARS
BUT TRUTH IS THERE’S NOTHING
WRONG WITH ACTUALLY FOLLOWING
THE SCIENCE ALLOWING POEM TO
MAKE THEIR OWN DECISIONS IN
MISSOURI WE HAVE HAD A FLEXIBLE
APPROACH IN THE BEGINNINGENING
OUR GOVERNOR HAS DEN A GOOD JOB
GIVING LOCAL COUNTIES ABILITY TO
MAKE THEIR OWN DECISIONS BUT
LISTEN, IF JOE BIDEN REALLY
WANTS TO DO MORE WHY DOESN’T HE
FOCUS HIS COVID RELIEF PACKAGE
ON VACCINE DISTRIBUTION?
AND ACTUALLY PUT THE BRUNT OF
THE PACKAGE THERE INSTEAD HE IS
SPENDING HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS ON STUFF LIKE ABORTION
PROVIDERS AND ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE.
THAT SHOWS YOU WHERE HIS
PRIORITIES ARE.
>> PEOPLE’S MONEY ONLY 9% IS
GOING TO COVID RELIEF, AND IT IS
CALLED THE COVID RELIEF PACKAGE.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT ALL OF THE PORK
I THINK WE HAVE A LIST OF SO
MUCH STUFF THAT LAWMAKERS HAVE
CRAMMED IN HERE.
>> COVIDY STUFF.
$1 TRILLION, THOUGH, HAS BEEN
NOT SPENT FROM PAST COVID-19
RELIEF BELL SO WHAT DOES THAT
TELL YOU DOES THAT TELL YOU THIS
IS EXCUSE THEY WANT TO SAY IT IS
COVID RELIEF BELL BUT EXCUSE TO
GET WHAT THEY NEED FOR THEIR
COMMUNITY AND THEIR BIG DONORS?
>> YEAH.
EXACTLY RIGHT.
IT IS ABOUT THEIR LEFT WING
AGENDA AND ACTUALLY THE WHITE
HOUSE HAS BEEN PRETTY FRANK
ABOUT THIS IF I THINK THEY
CALLED IT MOST PROGRESSIVE PIECE
OF DOMESTIC LEGISLATION IN A
GENERATION.
AND THAT’S ABOUT RIGHT.
NOTICE COVID IS NOWHERE IN THAT
SENTENCE.
YEEM YOU LOOK AT THEIR
PRIORITIES FUNDING ABORTION
PROVIDER AND ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE SHOVELING MONEY TO MONEY
TO BLUE STATES, WHO IS REVENUES
ARE ACTUALLY UP.
I MEAN IT IS JUST PURE POLITICS
MEANWHILE WHAT ABOUT WORKERS --
YOU KNOW ALL OF THEIR PROMISES
TO WORKERS ABOUT DIRECT RELIEF
THEY’VE SCALED THOSE BACK, AND
SCALED THOSE BACK.
SO WORKERS ARE GETTING LESS
VACCINE DISTRIBUTIONS ACTUALLY
GETTING LESS, AND I MEAN NOT AS
YOU SAID NOT LESS THAN 9% OF THE
MONEY GOAPG MEDICAL CODE RELIEF
ALL OF THE REST OF IT TO THEIR
SPECIAL INTEREST AND TO THEIR
LEFT WING AGENDA IT IS CRAZY.
>> YEAH.
WE KNOW A LOT OF PEOPLE WATCHING
RIGHT NOW LOOKING AT THAT 1.9
TRILLION THINKING OKAY BUT
WHERE’S MY CHECK?
YOU KNOW THERE ARE A LOT OF
PEOPLE SENATOR IN THIS COUNTRY
QHOR HURTING BAD.
AND IT IS GREAT THAT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT CAN OPEN UP OUR
WALLET THEIR WALLET UNCLE SAM
WALLET AND WRITE THEM A CHECK TO
HELP THEM THROUGH TOUGH TIME THE
PROBLEM REPUBLICANS HAVE IS WITH
ALL OF THAT OTHER STUFF RIGHT?
>> YEAH.
THAT’S EXACTLY RIGHT.
I MEAN, LISTEN, I SUPPORTED
DIRECT RELIEF TO WORKING
FAMILIES FOR MONTHS ON END AND
FACT THAT GOT IT IN LAST COVID
RELIEF PACKAGE BACK IN DECEMBER
THAT PRESIDENT TRUMP SIGNED I
THOUGHT IT SHOULD HAVE BEEN EVEN
MORE BACK THEN AND PRESIDENT
RIGHT ABOUT THAT HE WANTED IT
2,000 FAMILIES THAT’S WHAT IT
SHOULD HAVE BEEN SO THIS I’M ALL
FOR THAT.
THE PROBLEM IS, THAT THE REST OF
THIS BILL WHILE THEY’VE BEEN
SCALING BACK THE DEMOCRATS HAVE
RELIEF TO WORKING FAMILIES,
THEY’VE BEEN LOADING UP THEIR
OWN SPECIAL INTEREST PRIORITIES.
50 MILLION DOLLARS FOR ABORTION
PROVIDERRERS ENVIRONMENTALIST
LEFT WING CAUSE IS GETTING
MILLIONS AND MILLIONS IN THIS
WILL BELL, AND THAT’S JUST THE
STF WE KNOW ABOUT.
WAIT UNTIL THEY READ IT TODAY.
>> SURE WHAT ABOUT 350 BILLION
TO STATES AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
THAT SHUT EVERYTHING DOWN
WHEREAS OTHER STATES LIKE --
FLORIDA KEPT THINGS OPEN WITH A
LOWER UNEMPLOYMENT RATE, THE
STATES THAT HAVE A HIGH
UNEMPLOYMENT RATE LIKE NEW YORK
WHERE WE’RE SITTING, THEY WILL
BENEFIT FROM THIS.
ABSOLUTELY THEY WILL AND MANY OF
THE BLUE STATES THAT GET
BILLIONS UNDER THIS BILL THEIR
TAX REVENUES ARE ACTUALLY UP IN
2020.
THEY ENDED UP DOING BETTER THAN
THEY THOUGHT THAT THEY WERE
GOING TO.
AND AS YOU SAY THEY’VE ALREADY
GOTTEN BILLIONS IN PREVIOUS
PACKAGES.
SO THIS IS --
IT IS A LEFT WING GIVE AWAY.
IT IS A LEFT WING SOCIAL ALGD
THAT THEY’RE TRYING TO USE HERE
AND THEY’RE GOING TO DO IT ALL
WITHOUT REPUBLICAN SUPPORT, I
MEAN, THEY’RE NOT EVEN
ATTEMPTING TO GET REPUBLICAN
VOTE IN THE SENATE.
>> SO GOOD NEWS IS THEY THREW
OUT NANCY PELOSI BASICALLY
SYMBOLIC THREW OUT NANCY PELOSI
TRANSIT SYSTEM AND THROUGHOUT
CHUCK SCHUMER BRIDGE TO CANADA,
BUT YOU, YOU HAVE MORE TARGETED
RELIEF THAT MODERATE SO-CALLED
MODERATE DEMOCRATS ARE ASKING
FOR SO THAT WILL BE IN THE BILL.
BUT THAT’S INTERESTING SENATOR
RON JOHNSON READ THE WHOLE BILL
OUTLOUD TO DELAY ANY PASSAGE AT
00 PAGES BUT LET’S MOVE ON TO
TALK ABOUT SOME OF THE PRESIDENT
NOMINEE GETTING TURBULENCE ONCE
IS A CONTROVERSIAL PICK XAVIER
ATTORNEY GENERAL OF CALIFORNIA.
ONE OF THE CONTROVERSIAL QUOTES
THAT I WANT TO SHARE WITH YOU
THAT YOU KNOW ABOUT APRIL THIRD.
THERE ARE NOT CRIMINALS.
THEY HAVEN’T COMMITTED A CRIME.
AGAINST SOMEONE, AND THEY ARE
NOT ACTING VIOLENTLY OR IN A WAY
THAT’S HARMFUL TO PEOPLE AND I
WOULD ARGUE THEY ARE NOT HARMING
PEOPLE INDIRECTLY EITHER IF YOU
CALL THEM CRIMINALS IT IS EASIER
TO GET PEOPLE TO TURN AGAINST
THEM THAN IF YOU CALL THEM
UNDOCUMENTED IMMIGRANTS.
THAT’S HOW HE’S GOING APPROACH
THE BORDER.
THAT’S HOW HE WILL APPROACH HIS
JOB IF HE GETS A JOBS AT HHS.
>> ILLEGAL BORDER ENTRY IN THIS
COUNTRY IS A CRIME AND WHAT’S
INTERESTING WHEN I ASKED MERRICK
GARLAND IF HE SUPPORTED KEEPING
ILLEGAL ENTRY --
HE WOULDN’T ANSWER ME.
YEAH.
SO YOU SEE WHAT YOU SEE A
PATTERN HERE FROM BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION WHICH IS TO URN
IT A BLIND YOU TO WHAT’S GOING
ON AT THE BORDER WE ALREADY HAVE
ANOTHER CRISIS BUILDING AT THE
BORDER.
THEY KNOW IT, BY THE WAY.
AND YET THEY’RE DOING NOTHING.
SO THEY’RE GOING TO IT LEGAL
IMMIGRATION TORSE OPEN AND TRIED
TO CRIMINALIZE PRO-LIFE ADVOCACY
WHAT’S HIS PRIORITY BEEN GOING
AFTER --
FOLKS WHO ARE PRO-LIFE, IT HAS
BEEN PUSHING A HARD LEFT AGENDA.
>> REJECTED.
WHAT ARE HIS STANCES?
>> BECAUSE SIXTH PANEL IS
DEADLOCKED?
>> I THINK HE’S IN TROUBLE, AND
THAT’S GOOD NEWS BECAUSE THIS IS
A GUY WITH A RADICAL, RADICAL
LEFT WING RECORD, AND SO I HOPE
THAT SENATE DEMOCRATS TAKE HARD
LOOK AT THIS SAY IS THIS THE
KIND OF GUY WHO WANTS TO
PROSECUTE PRO-LIFE DIDN’TS GUY
IN BIRTH ABORTION AND USE
TAXPAYER MOWN TO FUND ABORTIONS,
I MEAN AGAIN THAT’S JUST
RADICAL.
>> PARTICULARLY DURING A GLOBAL
PANDEMIC, WHEN JOE BIDEN NUMBER
ONE PRIORITY IS GETTING RID OF
THE PANDEMIC YOU WOULD THINK
THEY WOULD HAVE --
SOMEBODY FROM THE HEALTH CARE
WORLD, OR SOMEBODY WHO WAS A
DOCTOR TO HEAD THAT UP.
BUT INSTEAD THEY’VE GOT THE
FORMER ATTORNEY GENERAL.
SENATOR I WANTED TO ASK YOU
ABOUT YOUR OFFICES UP ON THE
CAPITOL HILL COMPLEX.
AND HOUSE IS CANCELED TODAY’S
VOTES BECAUSE OF WORRIES AND THE
HEADLINE OUT OF THE WASHINGTON
POST IS CAPITOL POLICE INTEL
SHOWS MILITIA GROUP PLOTTING TO
TAKE THE CAPITOL TODAY BECAUSE
MARCH 4TH HISTORICALLY HAS BEEN
INAUGURATION DAY BEFORE THE 20TH
AMENDMENT.
WHAT DO YOU KNOW ABOUT THIS
THREAT AND HOW SERIOUSLY ARE
PEOPLE TAKING IT?
>> YOU KNOW, I ONLY KNOW WHAT
I’VE READ AND WHAT I SEE
REPORTED SO IF I PERSONALLY
HAVEN’T BEEN BRIEFED I’M NOT
AWARE OF ANY BRIEFINGS THAT’S
BEEN OFFERED TO SENATORS AT
LARGE ABOUT THIS.
YOU KNOW WE’RE PLANNING TO BE IN
SESSION TODAY AND TO GO ABOUT
OUR WORK.
AND I’LL JUST SAY THAT YOU KNOW
WE’VE GOT IF THERE ARE SERIOUS
THREATS THEN, OBVIOUSLY, WE HOPE
THOSE WILL BE REPORTED TO
MEMBERS THAT WILL BE ABLE TO
MAKE A DECISION BUT IN THE MEENL
TIME WE’VE GOT TO KEEP DOING THE
WORK THAT WE WERE SENT HERE TO
DO AND DO IT SAFELY AND
REASONABLY AS WE CAN.
J DO YOU THINK MAJOR GUARD DO
YOU STILL WANT THEM THERE AND
CONGRESSMAN HE SAID IT IS TIME
FOR THEM TO GO HOME.
>> OH.
I MEAN, I THINK THAT FACT WE’VE
GOT THOUSANDS OF NATIONAL GUARDS
MEN AND WOMEN AND YOU KNOW
CERTAINLY APPRECIATE THEIR
SERVICE BUT THE IDEA THAT
THEY’RE GOING TO BE THERE
INDEFINITELY THAT APPEARS TO BE
THE PLAN WE’VE HAD THESE
HEARINGS UP ON THE HILL RECENTLY
ABOUT JANUARY 6TH, AND FOLKS
HAVE BEEN ASKING OVER AND OVER
HOW LONG WILL THE GUARD BE ON
CAPITOL HILL?
NOBODY CAN GET AN ANSWER.
YEEM IT APPEARS TO BE INDEFINITE
I THINK THE IDEA OF KEEPING THEM
THERE INDEFINITELY A BASHED WIRE
FENCE AROUND CAPITOL IS CRAZY.
THIS IS THE PEOPLE’S HOUSE.
IT SHOULD BE OPEN TO THE PEOPLE.
AND JUST TO SAY THAT YOU KNOW
HEY, MAYBE FOR FOREVER, WE’LL
HAVE THE MASSIVE GUARD PRESENCE
AND HAVE IT FENCED OFF FROM THE
PUBLIC I THINK IS A WRONG
CHOICE.
WHANCH IS LIFE LIKE FOR YOU NOW
WITH BACKLASH FROM DEMOCRATS IN
PARTICULAR ABOUT --
ABOUT YOUR --
WOULD BE SPEECH ON JANUARY 6TH,
AND THE UNREST THAT WE ALL KNOW
ABOUT.
HAVE THINGS SETTLED DOWN FOR
YOU?
>> YOU KNOW, IT HAS BEEN --
TRULY IT HAS BEEN AMAZING TO SEE
THE OUTPOURING OF SUPPORT SINCE
THEIR EFFORTS TO CANCEL ME TO
CANCEL OTHER CONSERVATIVES TO
CANCEL ANYBODY WHO WON’T GO
WHROONG THEIR RADICAL LEFT
AGENDA, OF COURSE, THEY LIE
EVERY THIS WAY ABOUT MY
OBJECTION ON JANUARY 6TH THEY
LIE ABOUT MY POSITION AND IT
HASN’T WORKED THAT’S THE --
THAT’S THE GREAT THING YOU LOOK
AT MY SUPPORTS AND MY HOME STATE
OF MISSOURI YOU LOOK AT THE
SUPPORT FROM AROUND NATION THEY
HAVE UTTERLY FAILED BACKFIRED
ACTUALLY.
AND PING I THINK PEOPLE WANT
FOLKS TO TELL THE TRUTH AND KEEP
ON DOING THEIR JOB THAT’S
EXACTLY WHAT I’M GOING TO DO.
>> WE WANT EVERYBODY SAFE TODAY
AS THEY DO THEIR JOB ON THE
CAPITOL HILL COMPLEX.
SIR THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR